diego daniel
is in disbelief he's devastated that
player diego maradona has passed away
i'm sad because i knew this was coming
not so soon but the people that
surrounded him
never helped and he didn't want to be
helped i can't believe it
is my god it's the worst day of my life
thousands of people gathered in the
center of buenos aires to celebrate
maradona's life
and his love for argentina's national
team
was not just a football player for
argentina he was a national hero a man
who came from some of the poorest areas
in buenos aires
and made it to the top to the best
football clubs in the world
many of those who came here to say
goodbye to him come
from some of those areas from four areas
and they say that diego morona was one
of them
is from a slum in the capital
for me he was like the love of my
children i did not want to have this
news
i am destroyed i was too young to see
him play
but i know every goal by heart he gave
us dignity
so many times people here
celebrate the goals against england in
the 1986 world cup
three years after the war between both
countries over the malvinas falklands
islands
a goal that continues to be celebrated
today
i came because i felt it he was from
here represented us he waved our flag
gave us joy he filled us with joy in
front of the english we did not wage war
against them
but with the hand of god he gave the
people back their soul
a man who supported left-wing leaders in
latin america
like fidel castro nugochavez and
vindicated their fight against
imperialism argentina
is a synonym of the argentine dream that
dream of being of
being a footballer of staying in a huge
club
of playing and winning world cups so
uh he um as a footballer
um did what
none of us could do maradona will
receive
a hero's farewell he'll be lying in
state in the presidential palace
around the world maradona is referred to
as the best football player in the world
for his fans he was diego a man who in
spite of his enormous struggles
filled argentina with pride
[Music]
perez